we're a few weeks away from summer the
season of outings and blockbusters
that's why i feel that it's proper that
we're featuring 10 of the biggest
spitfires that the anime world has seen
yes the title is already a giveaway but
today i'll take you on a tour to meet my
favorite overpowered fire wielders in
anime oh and by the way this list isn't
in any specific order because trust me
fitting out 10 of my favorite fire users
in anime is hard already
[Music]
[Music]
who could forget roy mustang being a
legacy anime full metal alchemist
seemingly doesn't get talked about that
much that doesn't mean it didn't leave
its mark on the anime scene and for me
one of the reasons it did so is due to
the fiery charisma of roy mustang the
cool colonel may not be the modern
definition of overpowered but in the
context of fma he sure had a lot of
amazing feats i often talk about his
fights on the channel some which end up
being even more memorable than the elric
brothers fights that's just how much of
an impact the character has made on me i
also like how the show developed his
relationship with riza and i think that
that's one very important aspect of full
metal alchemist writing and building up
its characters
[Music]
like mustang faithan has that brooding
pretty boy appeal in contrast to mustang
however faithan is a more sinister
person that you wouldn't want to cross
overall one of the more powerful members
of the phantom troop veithan is the type
of person who wouldn't hesitate to get
his hands dirty in his quest the true
definition of silent but deadly if
historic demeanor and sadistic panchayat
for torture is anything to go by and
while feitan may not be associated with
fire the fight with zazan qualifies him
in my book rising sun was a breathtaking
sight to watch and seeing it in action
still gives me chills to this day
feithan has had a lot of fights but i do
think that the zazan fight is one of his
best and the one that catapulted him to
the top of my phantom troop member
rankings strongest phantom troop member
well not exactly but he does show that
he has more than earned his top spot
within the squad
why stop the momentum of the team leader
types let's proceed to someone who's had
experience leading a squad mario leona
how's this for a change of pace unlike
both mustang and faith on mario leona
embodies what everyone thinks of a
powerful fire wielder a loud aggressive
and short-tempered force regardless
there's something in mario leona that
allows her to be one of the best at
connecting with others and earning her
respect will take you far with that in
mind getting on a bad side is nothing
but bad news and it's pretty amazing
that mario leona has a perfect combat
record you'd expect these kinds of
mentor characters to be fed to the big
villains hey even yami had his moments
of shocking defeats but not this woman
just by having a lot of close calls my
favorite spell of hers has to be
canada's brachy and purgatory it's just
the perfect compliment to her go-getter
and physical fighting style and in anime
form it's presented in such a cool
manner with the blue flames
next up on the list is benimaru
[Music]
which one well the video is already a
spoiler and i'll be talking about fire
force's benimaru the character with the
same name from slime is also a cool
example of a badass user of flames but i
give the fire force character a nod for
being more closely associated with the
element and to keep the stream of
authority figures going because fire
forces benimaru is yet another example
of bad ass captains very maru has had a
lot of showcase fights we have the nifty
akitaru fight but the better one in my
opinion is the haran fight it's one of
fire force's many fights that simply
wowed me with its animation this is a
guy you'd want on your side despite
being short-tempered and disrespectful
he's a person that you can trust
personally i really like his philosophy
that puts him at odds with holy soul
as for someone who's the epitome of
burning passion his endeavour
endeavor probably needs no introduction
one of the world's top heroes has to
make an impact whatever he does wherever
he goes whether it be incinerating nomu
in his flames of fury or being an ever
looming presence that's proven to be an
anchor in both all might and dodoroki's
stories in addition to his amazing feats
battling villains and nomu i really like
how endeavour slowly developed as a
character there's little to like about
him when he's first introduced and it
stays that way most of the time there's
the pride that makes him off-putting to
some but as the story progresses we get
to see more of his perspective and how
he becomes a more sympathetic figure
he's one of the more engaging father
figures in anime and a lot of it has to
do with his redemption story
but on another note anime just isn't
enough to keep my spirits up after all
even the toughest battle shonen heroes
or the most overpowered isakai
protagonists eventually must face the
hardest fight of them all the battle
within that's why i'm very thankful for
today's sponsor better help better help
is an online service that helps you with
those mental and emotional struggles for
those having difficulty with self-esteem
like i did when i was around your age or
having trouble sleeping as well like i
still sometimes do in the present better
help offers their set of licensed
therapists to help with over 20 000
registered therapists in their network
you can easily find one whose sessions
are tailor-made just for you all you've
got to do is to get them to know you
more and you do that simply by filling
in a questionnaire signing up is super
simple and answering the questionnaires
are super easy once everything's said
and done you can start setting up
schedules at your own convenience to end
things in a good and hopeful note i'm
here to offer you 10
off your first month all you've got to
do is click the link in the description
box or go to
betterhelp.comtube get matched with a
therapist who'll always be ready to
listen and help
who says we can only stick to authority
figures especially when ace exists
[Music]
anyone out for a call brother while
lacking the powerful or intimidating
presence that the first half of our list
had ace trumps them all in terms of
being that one character who just feels
so ideal i bet a lot of one piece fans
dreamt of having someone as cool as ace
being their brother or guiding light in
contrast to loud luffy ace is more calm
collected and mature but don't let that
personality fool you for he's one of the
bravest characters in one piece his
loyalty is second to none and it's those
traits that have earned him a lot of
admiration from characters of the one
piece universe among one piece's loads
and loads of characters he's one of the
select few who truly made a mark even
after his time in the limelight has
ended both in and out of universe he's
not a shabby fighter but he's a
character i've always seen to be
stronger in terms of heart and the
ability to touch others instead of just
being an overpowered beatmore character
[Music]
and then
there's eskanolo
probably one of the most overpowered
characters of them all eskenor has
become a fan favorite due to the sheer
absurdities he puts out on screen the
man looks nothing close to intimidating
but underestimating him is the last
mistake that you'll ever make i'm sure
anyone who hasn't watched or heard of
seven deadly sins will be surprised if i
were to tell them that this is arguably
the strongest member of the main cast
but the record does speak for itself
eskenore has won his fights in dominant
fashion and you've got my previous
videos to refer to for that in addition
to his impeccable performance in fights
what i like about eskinot from a meta
point of view is the fun gimmick given
to him having powers that work
accordingly to the time of day isn't too
common off the top of my head there's
nanami but not many others still i think
eskimos application of it is one of the
most impressive ones out there man i
still feel sad that they did esknow
dirty with that supposed crowning battle
against meliodas
and we follow moustache man with another
moustache man here's yamamoto
i really enjoy yamamoto as a character
for his duality as captain commander of
the goatee 13 he's ruthless stiff and
intimidating there's no one you'd like
to piss off more than yamamoto amongst
the captains of seoul society no one
trust me but the bonus episodes and
fillers reveal a goofy sign to him that
we'd expect from the textbook image of
an old man who's had his best years
behind him what exactly led yamamoto to
become head captain of the goat day 13
is an event shrouded in mystery but one
thing is certain he more than justifies
his billing as the strongest force in
the entire goat day 13 so much that even
aizen had to think of a way to mitigate
his powers eisen and yamamoto still
finds a way to overcome that not by
skill though but by brute force and we
haven't seen yamamoto's full power yet
it's something that will be revealed in
bleach thousand year war and i'll tell
you as early as now that it lives up to
the hype
[Music]
as we head towards the home stretch of
the list how about stopping by and
appreciating here
[Applause]
now here's the thing i think he is the
character that started it all not the
trend of fire wielders but my interest
in those standoffish characters with
that cool edgy vibe as far as i'm
concerned he ate is by far the coolest
member of team yusuke back when i
started watching yuuyu hakusho and it's
not just because of his overall aura
you've got the cool swordsmanship and
the visually appealing black dragon
flames too then there are those fighting
skills on full display fans remember
when he showed that he's not just a
speedster but also immensely powerful
stopping bowie's axe with one hand ala
eisen or at the time he managed to go
toe-to-toe with yusuke proving that
protagonist supporting characters don't
always have to be left in the dust by
the main hero who gets all the power-ups
yeah he a makes it on this list due to
the rule of call he's an awesome
character who has a fan base that he
deserves
could we have a fire wielder list
without natsu
yeah legit question because natsu is the
shonen protagonist who's practically
synonymous with fire as an element sure
there are others who use it but the one
who almost exclusively uses the element
i can't think of others off the top of
my head maybe sooner for khr fans out
there but i don't think he's anywhere as
well known as natsu is who doesn't know
the ever passionate natsu in his wide
arsenal of fire based attacks being the
fire dragon slayer he's got multiple
tricks up his sleeve but it's not until
later when his overpoweredness comes in
full display yes the power of friendship
and all that but even discounting that
we can clearly say that natsu has some
of the strongest power ups over the
course of the anime now i'm not sure if
i want to outright spoil it for you but
i'll give you a hint by telling you to
look at his transformations and true
identity
and there we have it my favorite amongst
the overpowered fire wielders in anime
i'm pretty sure my list looks different
to yours so head on down to the comments
and tell me who you would have in a top
10. if you enjoyed the video don't
forget to drop a like share and check
out the other videos on my channel too
you can also check out vinnie tube's
other social media avenues there's the
discord the patreon and the instagram
and all the links for those are in the
description box i hope you had fun
watching this and i hope to see you
again soon